[Music]
well The Fatman I'm Batman I'm Kevin
Smith I am mark barnard oh my God we're
gonna geek and talk about geeky stuff
right here at the one and only home of
fat man on Batman the scum and villainy
canteen right here in Hollywood
California put your hands together so
the folks know you're real at home okay
before we go anywhere before we dive
into this week's geek news and whatnot
I watched last night rewatched San
Junipero episode of Black Mirror
did you know you've seen this yes
anybody who has not seen it get ready to
have it [ __ ] spoiled hard no I won't
spoil it it's something absolutely to be
beheld if you've never seen it there's a
TV show on Netflix called Black Mirror
kind of like a modern-day Twilight Zone
right but way more depressing way yes
where at the end of it you feel dirty
after every one of them and stuff and
they had one the only one where you
never felt dirty at the end of it which
is an episode called San Junipero and I
wanted to rewatch it cuz when I was in
New York couple weeks back for the New
York Comic Con I interviewed Charlie
Booker the guy that created the show and
we were talking about the episode and he
said some interesting things all right
now I've got that I'm gonna re-watch it
through the prism and it's one of these
episodes that once you've seen it you
you know it kind of there's something
spoiled about it forever like you can
only see it first for the first time and
it is a wonder because it treats its
audience with with such incredible
intelligence like unlike most things
that are written movies TV shows where
every [ __ ] aspect of spoon-fed so
that even the dumbest member of the
audience can understand what's going on
Sanju Tamara doesn't do that for the
first half hour it is frustrating
because you're like I don't understand
what is going on what are the rules of
this so watching it the second time
you know what the twist is gonna be and
so that was missing like instead of like
the gut punch of like oh oh now I get it
something
replaced it and that was pure emotion
motion of the sword emotion emotionality
no that's not a word I
it was pure allow it emo thank you very
much let's say it was pure emo I was
[ __ ] bawling so hard and it was
amazing I'm just sharing this as a way
for those of you if you ever find
yourself in the situation you're with
somebody with a domestic partner of some
sort man woman whatever the [ __ ] it is
human being though and the idea is
you're in a [ __ ] fight or you're just
like oh [ __ ] this person and you're not
really into each other
throw that episode on man like all of a
sudden you start rolling tears my wife
who is hating me that morning when we
woke up and [ __ ] I started watching that
she like rolled into the beds like I
[ __ ] love you I want to go to zan
Junipero with ya so it's it not only is
it a brilliant piece of writing is a
brilliant piece of makeup as well like
you know back in the day when you're a
kid maybe you play a song or something
like that
now you can literally throw somebody
else's art up and be like this how I
feel about our life together and it
rolls tears is a powerful piece of
writing like even knowing what's coming
it still worked like gangbusters and
then you start to see other little
elements to it
performances in it are off the charts
wonderful it's just a really human story
and in a show where it is pretty bleak
across the boards it's the one episode
that's very life-affirming even though
technically it's about death see I just
put on a little philipbaillie and that
makes a little better what Philip belli
do you spend like easy yeah I'm working
on my falsetto I'm gonna take it on the
road Luther Vandross does that make your
wife feel better if you're singing a
song under you're an easy lover it makes
her feel wanted oh really she's not
difficult she's easy like Sunday morning
another one that also works you got a
long road I'm a watch on whole episode
of television four minutes man you just
the magic of the iPod fair enough
what have you been up to uh I have been
still gainfully unemployed it is fun
employed I'll call it wait so your show
you're done working on the show working
on the show I went up to the set a
couple weeks ago we talked about at the
last scum and villainy podcast which
just went up today apparently so hooray
but yeah I spent I spent four days in
the middle of nowhere Massachusetts
making it look like Maine with actors
who are far too good to be speaking my
words because Jesus like I kept
apologizing to everybody look I'm sorry
I'm sorry this isn't better I'm sorry
it's three o'clock in the morning and
you're in the middle of the woods in
Massachusetts freezing your asses off
because I wrote exterior night instead
of exterior day - like can we get mr.
depressing off the [ __ ] set please
and also like crying in the corner
because they're saying my lines and talk
to us the first time I'd ever been
moving yeah where people are saying
things that I wrote and so they were
they were they were very surface tears
hopefully didn't annoy good could the
guy crying in the back keep it down
we're getting it on the mics I only got
that once and I have been putting
together a new podcast which I'm kind of
excited about but you cheatin [ __ ] what
is I am I am a flirt I'm an easy lover
yeah you are the Filippelli of this
[ __ ] it is it's called the Battlestar
Galactica oh that's great now entitled
what's it about it is an episode by
episode walked through Battlestar
Galactica
me and Tricia Helfer six Caprica Six and
a bow and I'll hurt a girl
Alberta girl and she apparently had
never seen the show really yes I just
shot up I never watched she's like I did
like dubbing for ADR and I saw like some
early cuts without graphics and special
effects I've never seen this show by
fans have seen the show he's like I was
gonna start already watching like that's
a [ __ ] podcast don't you leave with
Mike so we're gonna do this and so we're
doing it right and so every episode how
many episodes you go there
77 episodes including the two-part
miniseries what's awesome about that as
you know there's an ending inside yes
this is not gonna take like with this
show we'll do this until we drop dead
you know yeah
there's no like conclusion there's no
summer break or anything like that but
at least with that there's an end in
sight where you're like we get a 77 were
[ __ ] done we'll have a party
how could she have not watched it
although you know she admitted as much
to me at the London Film and Comic Con
maybe we were drunk I don't know it was
10 o'clock in the morning we're in
London who can say and when I passed her
in the hallway
she didn't I didn't oh yeah she's lovely
as [ __ ] I mean I met her years ago at
San Diego comic-con I did a what was it
I guess I was her there for I think I
moderated a Battlestar Galactica panel
so this time for London foam Comic Con
she passed me and it wasn't until she
went through the double doors that I was
like oh [ __ ] that's six from Battlestar
Galactica but then the next person that
passed me was what I thought was the
world's best Terence Stamp cosplayer I'd
ever seen in my life and I said that to
my god I was like did you [ __ ] see
that Tarrant step cosplayer and she was
like that was Terence Stamp so I didn't
get to talk to her but that's that's a
dope idea yeah she's real cool and and I
get to be the nerd and she gets to be
the one who's there and and it'll be a
match made in heaven
fingers crossed and it'll be wine so
again oh really guys get drunk later
hopefully what were you a big fan of the
show I was a huge fan
yeah I love that show like I was I was
the evangelist for Entertainment Weekly
when I when I was working there like I
was the first one who watched all of it
mmm was like mother [ __ ] we have to
cover the [ __ ] out of the show and I
wrote recaps every week and I got it on
the cover of the magazine when I left
the thing that they do magazines used to
do this and if they still do but when
you leave working for magazine they give
you like a farewell cover where they
will somehow superimpose you into the
cover that most represents you owe us to
take it home but not for the news staff
or the new Sam but just a little like
thinking put on your
and so my cover was its its mayor
McDonald and six and then me in the
middle kind of sandwiched between the
president and and Caprica and my head I
may or may not show that to her cuz
that's weird
I'm a fan don't mind me just get in the
van does this rag smell funny don't ya
well don't record in a van I might send
the wrong message you're like we're
trying to be economical we can't let
them know where we are
you got out whenever you start recording
yeah we did one so far we're gonna Bank
like six or seven before we launch
here's my challenge to get [ __ ] ten
then do one here live like run the
episode and stuff and you have to run it
with the sound down which little
irritating for everybody else but if you
put up subtitles [ __ ] it they could read
everybody reads TV now at the end of the
day I used to try to get my wife to
watch like a bunch of French movies like
oh my god I'm too tired to read but now
everything she watches on Netflix or
shows from like Denmark and [ __ ] and
they're all heavily [ __ ] subtitled
all home about how to kill a husband so
tends to send you know perros slang
exactly I'm like let's watch this it's
hopeful alright man you got some news do
we have a special guest for our news
no we'll bring her in later on first
we'll do some news and then we'll bring
we got a guest tonight man Tiffany Smith
is going to join us up here and chitchat
but first let's do the news let's get
through the news so they may announce a
release date for the Punisher yeah I saw
those yeah I mean I didn't even have to
see this I could have called this I
think we did yeah they released the
release date for the Punisher which is
big news now to release the release date
yes
not just the [ __ ] show the leg ready
we're gonna tell you when it's happening
well now they're [ __ ] G [ __ ] thanks
man
there are trailers for trailers and
those [ __ ] things good idea five
seconds of whatever
stay tuned for two minutes of whatever
they did that a lot for Batman be
Superman when before the trailer they
did a trailer for the trailer of that
moment where Superman like in the Bruce
Wayne dream where he's Batman's got his
hands above him and Suman takes his mask
off and [ __ ] Batman's got the most
perfect head of hair you ever seen in
your life they did that that I remember
that was a trailer because it was just
that moment it ended with him and his
[ __ ] big mane of hair and I was just
like that's sexy but yeah so this they
finally announced the release date and
the release date for the Punisher
they're putting all what 9 10 13 13
[ __ ] episodes Wow
yeah on November 17th which ironically
is the same day as Justice League I
think maybe so once again just one isn't
that weird just when DC's like finally a
little space for ourselves and [ __ ]
Marvel's like hold on don't forget us
like four is unzipping his punisher dick
and as i go ahead by the way you thought
you had two weeks to yourselves know
think about how ingenious this is eat
and by comparison people are gonna say
kinder things about the punisher by
virtue of the fact that they have 13
episodes to tell a story
whereas Justice League they just
released the intent of the running time
it is 100 any 121 minutes with credits
so that means it's an under two hour
movie which I'm I'm all for man believe
me I've sat through many movies where I
didn't go to [ __ ] Blade Runner yet
because I don't have six weeks to put
aside I mean to watch the movie in a
theater and stuff so please let me
rotate yourself when you watch Blade
Runner so like the totally it needs we
need intermission like in the old days
but this movie being under two hours I
think that's smart
on one hand on the other hand it's a lot
of story to try to tell in two hours you
think yeah especially given that most of
the audience for Punisher and Justice
League of the same audience yeah and so
I just I want to know what somebody will
have to do the numbers for me what the
impact of people staying home for a
weekend to watch Punisher immediately
will be
on opening weekend grosses for good dose
I don't think it hurts it I think look
it's not like you're gonna spend opening
weekend going to see the Justice League
six times which is roughly the amount of
time it takes to watch The Punisher so
you know I think you were gonna go see
the Justice League definitely once maybe
twice that weekend now what it does is
maybe hamstrings the audience ability to
go see it a second time because you're
like wow I'm [ __ ] knee deep and the
Punisher and stuff like that which
sounds filthier that I meant it but you
know what I'm talking about at the end
of the day I don't think I've seen some
people online going oh my god is
Marvel's big fat [ __ ] you to DC I don't
know if it's a big fat [ __ ] you it seems
opportunistic to jump on to that date
but I don't think it hurts either cause
you I think it's it's a thin [ __ ] you it
was not a big fat [ __ ] you you know and
I and I an emaciated [ __ ] you yeah we're
gonna withered from the god Pan from the
grave [ __ ] you but they're doing so well
that's the weird thing and then you know
historically movie division and TV
division don't have much to do with one
another so whoever's dropping it on the
you know dropping these Marvel Netflix
series on the theatrical dates it's not
even like you could point the finger at
Kevin Feige or something like this I'd
see some definite Blofeld [ __ ] where
he's just like pointing anaconda let's
do it
yeah really press the button could you
imagine you're that good at your job and
you get to [ __ ] around as well we're
just like this hurts doesn't it
okay so that's gonna be a busy weekend
for everybody unless we get to see it a
little early do you have any in at
Warner Brothers to go see Justice League
early no I mean I used to be a
journalist
so yes people might remember me
sometimes but turns out when you no
longer work for like the LA Times they
stop giving as much of us talk about you
[ __ ] fat man I'm Batman don't never
seen
credibility finding that out re it's
nice to be able to walk in any place in
LA times in my badge now I walk in its
this fat man on Batman and they're like
the porn theater is that way yeah like
yes you are what do you want I want to
come see your movie I don't know I'll
try and work it a little bit I didn't I
can shake moschini and see what I'd get
into me too
yeah I get I got one many curves I can
make this work
I'm trying to think if I know anybody
there anymore I mean like really know
them not like I knew him in a different
life or something like that I don't know
I got no connects I mean I know people
at the CW and [ __ ] that's how I saw
Batman vs Superman early I was up doing
an episode of the flash and they were
like hey they're giving us a screening
do you want to go and I was like oh my
god I'm [ __ ] making the flash and I
get to see this [ __ ] early what a gift
and then the movie ended I was like
taking it back no but so I got to see it
early because of the the show so I don't
I don't have any ends this time man
we're just gonna have I don't mind I'll
buy a ticket [ __ ] like that I will say
this I think that actually Marvel doing
this is a bit of a favor to Justice
League because I think Justice League
will not gross as much as say Wonder
Woman oh really I think so I think I'm
calling that right now I think it gross
is less than Wonder Woman
why why do you feel that because if
Wonder Woman I mean look let's do the
dumb math like let's say Wonder Woman is
a beautiful [ __ ] fantastic film and
that's why I made as much as it did but
let's do the dumb math Wonder Woman's
got one hero in it justice leaves got 96
[ __ ] the movie make more money more
heroes equal more money I don't think so
and I think that the reason why people
were going to these movies at all was
they wanted to see Superman Batman and
Wonder Woman together oh my god he was
good at water was like [ __ ] tasty
thanks I thought it was awesome for a
second but I think the Trinity was the
big poll and they gave us the Trinity
already and I don't think that cyborg or
flash or Aquaman even put you that much
over that bar
Aquaman though alcaman might like they
got a tee up a new movie coming out and
and the trailers like seems like he gets
a lot of screen time it seems like my mo
is having a good time doing it so maybe
he's the sneak attack secret weapon it
could be but Wonder Woman was amongst
many things a legit cultural movement
yeah there were people going two three
four times taking people they knew to
the movie cuz they might not have seen
taking their moms and grandmom's and
their daughters and Girl Scout troops
and everybody that ever met that might
have X X chromosomes to [ __ ] see
Wonder Woman right and I don't think
that exists for Justice League I think
we've seen these heroes before at least
the ones we've wanted to see and I think
that the Punisher is a pretty decent
scapegoat if you want one listen we
didn't do as well as Wonder Woman but
they released punished at the same
weekend how are we supposed to know how
are you serious what you're saying
you're positing that right now Warner
Bros is like oh thank God for The
Punisher bullet a little bit really a
little bit of trap door is there is it
tracking the Justice League movie I've
never paid attention than that sort of
stuff it's not that they haven't
released track you know numbers you know
numbers yet how far away are we we are
three weeks no I saw a billboard me in a
place where I never normally oh in the
valley I saw a big Justice League
billboard on Ventura so they're gearing
the [ __ ] up it's it's happening whether
we want it to or not we all wanted but
it happens also what after Thor
Thor's on the 3rd of November there's a
huge [ __ ] month when is the last Jedi
Kamel December 15 14 if you're lucky so
it's still on but uh but man what all
right November is packed one more month
one more reason to stay alive three
movies all right what else we go
speaking of Netflix and The Punisher
distracted by this do these go on a
drink of some sort to use Franken berry
in a drink it's [ __ ] genius what is
it what's the drink I'm not an alcohol
person but I might drinking about it
cereal in it force ghost wait whoa
River rescue rough day smuggling around
the plethoric we know everything the
Frank and Burt no Frankenberry that's
why I picked up Franken berry infused
Tito's vodka mixed berry puree ice
blocks this has turned me into an
alcoholic man
right on well done JC okay
back to you yeah Netflix is committing
to 80 original movies for 2018 and to
afford all of these not a single one of
them is gonna be mine I'll tell you that
[ __ ] much I've been in there to pitch
many things in each time they're like oh
we love you and they never pick it up
they I just think they want to make sure
that like I keep giving them my $9.99
every month and sure I think that's what
it's about I think pretty sure that's
why they take my meeting they're like if
we don't take the meeting you might
cancel and we always need those subs
we're a slave to the sobs but yeah they
did eight original movies last year
slash this year they're gonna do 80 next
year I saw one I didn't watch it yet but
I saw a Mick G movie called the
babysitter Wow
yeah did anybody see it holy [ __ ]
there's a movement Ally it's good yeah
but I saw an ad for it or you know
whatever you call the [ __ ] poster or
something like that and I clicked on it
because it didn't look familiar and then
I saw Mick G did it and there's mental
note oh so I'm gonna watch that later
but that's an original flick and they're
not putting up billboards firm or
anything they're just happening yeah I
mean like remember on HBO back in the
day they'd be like we made a [ __ ]
movie can you believe it it's a movie
marketed the fog out of it Netflix is
just like there's 19 movies and you'll
love every one of them [ __ ] and did
you watch that warmachine movie with
Brad Pitt no I did I did I look good but
it was okay wasn't what I hoped I
thought it looked like it was like they
were like from the makers of the big
short and I'm such an idiot dude I
literally work in that business but I
believe marketing you know holy [ __ ]
this is gonna be great it'll be exactly
like that and it wasn't I love the big
shirt I've watched that movie
incessantly my wife thinks it's because
she's like I think you watch it because
it's way smarter than you and you want
to be as smart as it and I was like
maybe because I still don't understand
what happened but to be fair I still in
under hand so understand what happened
at the end of trading places either so
that was like 30 years ago so I'm not
good with finance porkbelly's where you
get bacon yeah frozen orange juice
concentrate as in a bacon lettuce and
tomato sandwich yeah I don't know how
the [ __ ] it works either Forbes did an
article I'm using last year on what
happens at the end of trading places
because nobody [ __ ] knows like you
need business journalists to explain how
shorting and buying selling time I saw
one throw why are we selling fell fell I
don't [ __ ] know how that works nobody
knows that I worked all I knew is that
Eddie Murphy one at the end and that's
all we cared about yeah and it dude gets
[ __ ] by a gorilla oh my god that's
like and for comedy
all right so eighty flicks on that flip
it he's like some ethics there reason
they have eight billion dollars to spend
that's you know where they got it from
me from you from all these people here
that's where they get that money and
also debt because giant companies can
carry debt but I can you I mean I know
that's like asking you to big short it
but can you explain what that means big
companies carry debt it just means that
as you can borrow as much as you can
borrow provided that they think your
company is worth as much as they think
it is okay so given this a publicly
traded company or now it is a publicly
traded company so provided that
subscription rates stay high provided
that they keep winning Emmys for [ __ ]
provided that they keep on showing that
people want more and more and more they
can borrow more and more and more
against it but business but at a certain
point like don't you want to be when ru
is solvent when you're not in debt
anymore like wouldn't you want to be
worked from a place of profitability not
debt you would want to but giant
corporations like that almost all of
them carry some level of debt thank you
[Music]
that was the stock bail did I win if I
get in Riva rescue can I have a [ __ ]
fruity drink she was like stop talking
about she had fun playing Netflix
apparently those Marvel shows are never
gonna end they're just gonna keep doing
it they're gonna keep doing them until
until Marvel starts its own app along
with the Disney theme then they'll do it
for them
oh you think yeah do you think they'll
jump over there and do it yeah but
Netflix pays them for that show who
would pay him at Disney would be like
them having Disney would be because
people be like that's a reason for me to
get the Disney app so I come on
daredevil it's the same place you can
watch [ __ ] Mickey's clubhouse should
go watch daredevil as well pretty much
speaking of streaming apps Star Trek
discovery gets a second season already
y'all ready so it must be doing well
it's doing well in the way that they
will never tell us how well it's doing
beyond we're gonna keep making more of
them right it's one of those where they
said we're getting more subscriptions to
CBS all access than we've ever gotten
before despite the fact it's a brand new
service we don't they just opened last
month yeah like it turns out that my
grandma isn't getting that many
subscriptions for NCIS reruns but holy
[ __ ] people want to watch Star Trek so
no yeah the 2019 I think is what it's
coming out have you watched any more
than the first two I've watched now the
first five and it gets better and it
gets weirder and it also gets a little
bit worse er if that's a word hey if
emotional layer is a word that we're
sarissa would like they're doing some
really interesting things with with an
in character whom I still don't know why
her name is Michael but [ __ ] it her name
is Michael and she's conflicted in some
really interesting ways mm-hmm but it
doesn't feel like it's going anywhere
that quickly and the Klingons are still
a [ __ ] mystery that don't make any
real sense but are you a walking dead
guy I am NOT I dropped out a couple
seasons ago oh yeah I'm very up current
so I watched the season premiere which
was also the hundredth episode of the
show and after a long season last year
where it was like do something Rick do
but could do something rakaat dammit
he's not gonna do anything this season
open with a pretty strong do something
what did he do he didn't shoot negan
when he had a [ __ ] chance I'll tell
you that much man like he what did he do
counted what you did he was just like
I'm gonna count to ten on seven he
started shooting but to be fair he let
negan do a twenty minute monologue prior
to that at any point he could have put a
[ __ ] bullet in his open mouth and he
was like wow two words in you got him
gone he's gonna be with us with a while
longer I think [ __ ] they're really
pulling the taffy on this guy I dropped
out of that show look I don't know
[ __ ] just before terminus I think and
I tube back in for the negan premiere
like who are we gonna kill right and I
kind of realized for myself that that
there is no ending of this show that
makes me feel good about having watched
this show look at that far down the road
because I mean it's gonna be on forever
they're never gonna cancel it because
it's to be honest the only thing that
AMC has going for it fo hey and hey that
being said Stevens season seven a comic
book man
[Applause]
everything drafts in the wake of Walking
Dead it's true I believe me I know I
don't have a naught into my own I am
cannibalizing the audience of Robert
Kirkman you can be a Remora on that
giant eel and that's fine yes I don't
think of it as a Remora on the eel I
think of it as me surfing on Kirkman's
long dick all the way till midnight but
so like if I'm watching that show which
will probably never end but at what some
player will kiss every show does what's
gonna be the resolution that made all of
this carnage in pain and agony and
suffrage having been worth the trip they
they cure you know zombie-ism yeah all
right cool that's an answer I don't
think so but but that has to be where
it's going right they have steadfastly
said that it's never gonna be what
happens yeah but by the time you're
ready to shut down you're like ah [ __ ]
it let's cure it let's let them all live
happily ever after
I'm just hoping he gets to the end with
both hands intact still in the comics
not so lucky
all right so wait we weren't talking
about Walking Dead we were talking about
discovery discovery so you still watch
beyond the first two but I will Jason
Mewes is loving it yeah which is crazy
because Jason Mewes and Star Trek never
went together to thinkI for a guy like
him you know the one that he gravitated
toward naturally was the JJ Abrams
version because that was less thinking
and more [ __ ] wrong just blah blah
like it's more of a movie for experience
it should be seems to like this new Star
Trek yeah so more that if you want more
that anybody watching discovery yeah do
you like it don't get defensive you'll
get do I like it all right [ __ ] you guys
sue me it's entertaining are you
watching the Orval hey I didn't ask you
know are you watching the orrible I'm a
couple episodes back but I'm watching
you are watch now
I'm not apparently they're very similar
yes they both are Star Trek what are you
yes so my man said Orville's better how
do you feel about that I feel like if I
had never seen Star Trek before but
always heard about it I was like
wouldn't it be fun if Star Trek was just
like 10 percent funnier that's what the
Orval is is that what it is Star Trek
but 10 percent funnier absolutely
like next generation Star Trek even but
it's not bad it's just I would have an
amazing title that put it right on Front
Street that Star Trek but 10% funnier
yeah
new and improved Star Trek yeah kinda
this time the tribbles are called
merkins sea 10% I like Orvil it's it's
doing well I think on Fox I don't love
it because again I've seen lots of Star
Trek so okay I know all of where it
comes from but yeah it's totally fine my
kid loves it I'm just not as in love
with Odysseus okay all right what's the
next story uh it turns out that once
upon a time David Fincher was in line to
directed Star Wars movie Oh what yeah
that's news I never heard that when he
was in the running for Episode seven
which was a force force awakens yeah and
then was apparently in talks for nine
but pulled out because he said it's a
crazy amount of stress and I don't think
it's worth it I would imagine this is a
guy could pretty much do anything he
wants like why why leave that sort of
freedom behind to go into a world where
there are constrictions left and right-t
sir thank you
he certainly that's the logic bel
whatever we make sense somebody hits it
it made why what would he other than
like oh my god I made a Star Wars which
isn't even his thing it's somebody
else's thing what does it get him where
he can just stay in his world literally
do whatever he wants and if he wants to
do a space opera he totally could he
doesn't even have to do that one but
it's a it's an interesting idea like the
idea of David Lynch doing Return of the
Jedi like the idea of David Fincher
doing force awakens yeah like 48 takes
of anything
david fincher we're gonna keep doing
this now Carrie I get your old come on
Harrison don't break another leg but we
got to do 140 takes of this I wonder if
he would have built the Millennium
Falcon if he was doing force awakens
because that's what hurt Harrison Ford's
leg is the Millennium Falcon so if that
didn't exist his leg never gets hurt it
was the door the drop-down ironically
the [ __ ] thing that you need to get
on the Falcon broke his [ __ ] leg do
you think that's like the sliding doors
it puts us back in the right timeline
what timeline would that be the one
where we don't have the president we
have yes if Harrison Ford doesn't break
his ankle are we suddenly back where
we're supposed to be I think there's a
butterfly effect there yeah awesome all
right yeah we fix you guys where's the
[ __ ] logic bail nobodies by the logic
but he said he said quote you have to
really clear your head if you read you
have to be really ready to make sure
this is something you want to do either
way it's two years out of your life 14
hours a day seven days a week there's no
getting around it so he removed himself
for consideration for episode 9 I could
totally see that that makes sense why he
doesn't need that be fun maybe on one
level but more of a headache than
anything else and he's got to answer to
somebody he doesn't need that he can go
off and do what's he doing right now
anybody know
Fincher you did mine hunter that show my
lost my wife to that show for four days
[ __ ] Fincher did that [ __ ] wife
stealing pieces [ __ ] she loved that show
she's like you should watch this it's
very smart I was like he's as smart as
the big short and she goes nothing's as
big as the big business nothing's as
smart as the big short to you I think
he's also been toying with 20,000
Leagues Under the Sea since forever oh
I'd watch that him with the Nautilus and
a giant [ __ ] squid yeah I think Will
Smith was attached at one point I think
I'd watch him do anything what was the
last thing Fincher did gone girl I
didn't watch that no
I guess he's been working on that show I
know those look amazing dad shall we
dive in does this go in the does this go
in the thing it's just a shoe a shoe
term I gotta chill today if I just you
eat the cereal and then you chase it
down with the booze with are those like
ice cubes that are made of something of
punch all right where are we going next
oh let's see I saw Geo storm over the
weekend how was that that was the Dean
Devlin movie right what I I had most of
a theater to myself it made dirt we call
that a tusk that is good it's like a
daiquiri yeah
I'm not a Buddhist guy but that's good
he's so badly though oh my god I want to
eat these so much no man it starts here
and then it ends with me [ __ ]
mainlining hotdogs and M&Ms in a gutter
somewhere I've been there before man's
best to stay right where it is this is
the biggest goal puke so Gio Sturm if
you've ever seen a Dean Devlin slash
roland emmerich joint yes this is that
he made that movie for know about 1492
what 2012 that's it
numbers in it it's also about the rape
of the natural world but you know less
Columbus and more giant waves right it's
not good here oh it's not produced
Independence Day he did he was a writer
on Independence Day right around day
after tomorrow right around Stargate
Stargate as well is that a rollin in
there that's rolling in right joint
Spike Lee Teuk there and then they had a
parting of the ways
nobody there to fight fallen out that a
big fight so they went they were Wow you
know what I'm saying own the room
[ __ ] why down here when you
could be like hi I'm an ardent yeah
Barry White it how you doing well I'm
not old to do with this power I know
it's it's kind of amazing
it's time so yes so he made this Geo
storm movie which has been on the shelf
for about three years
oh that means they went and did reshoots
yeah a very expensive reshoot for about
two months new director and they added
new characters they cut a bunch out of
it you can tell all of it it's not
particularly well done except that [ __ ]
blows up good cuz at the end of the day
that's kind of all in there for what is
the Geo storm just a killer storm is it
like when how though
plants came after us in the M night
movie The Happening yeah it's the trees
ya know it's apparently if I can
summarize this shitty plot handily it's
it's global warming has pushed the
environment to the point where storms
are increasing all around the world at
an alarming rate so they create this
giant satellite that can regulate the
environment and atmospherics but of
course said satellite goes bad because
that's what [ __ ] happen so Gerard
Butler scientist sure is
[Laughter]
he's the he is the if you've ever seen a
roland emmerich Dean Devlin movie he's
the the guy who knows science you have
to explain it to everybody who doesn't
want to believe him
guy right so here's the podcast
communicator science and so he goes back
up to this [ __ ] Space Station to fix
it before all of these individual storms
form some giant sinking all over the
world geo storm because that's a thing
another car from the late nineties is
that would we draw would we drown or
it's like it's it's basically it's the
beginning of Flash Gordon it's like hot
hail it's [ __ ] like like Gordon that
was that was that was a choice though oh
yeah totally Ming was giving us bad
weather client is on board he was doing
it cuz he was [ __ ] bored piece of
[ __ ] that would be but this movie is
just happening naturally well no because
that light went rogue and did it it
almost went rogue except there's bad
politicians who are being villains who
want to somehow remove science from the
earth and bring it back to the Dark Ages
so that America can once again be the
dominant force in the planet what an
imaginative script yeah
spoiler the bad guys Ed Harris because
of course he is all Ed Harris is in this
yeah why didn't you start with that I
like that Harris did you see mother
no and again ma it's interesting to
watch at the very least at the very
least good yes I do think it is good but
it's you know it's an allegory so for
what you don't want me to tell you you
got to see it I'll talk about it but
it's it's an allegorical film so in that
way most people go to the movies you
know they get their [ __ ]
pretty much on Front Street like here's
your bad guy here's your good guy and
stuff like that this is a movie where
everything on screen means something
else is it an allegory for what it's
like to date Darren Aronofsky
you know sure oh right so remember what
it was like to date Darren Aronofsky's
so I can't recall exactly but he was in
it my point and he's pretty wonderful in
it at Arras I've always liked him in
everything man remember you as John
Glenn and the right stuff so good yeah
Sam Shepard and then just for you know a
movie I watched to death I love all the
HBO political movies and smart people
movies like they did too big to fail
about the banking system anything I
can't understand HBO generally does a
movie about so he was in game changer
which was the story of John McCain and
Sarah Palin and he was a pretty
excellent John McCain man ed Harris but
I've heard he's can be surly I also buy
that yeah having having spent some time
with Scott Glenn on the on the castle
rock set it seems as if actors of a
certain age can be surly what do you
think that's about man I think it's just
like [ __ ] tired of this the same way
that like your granddad wants to sit in
the [ __ ] good chair and get the good
piece of chicken every day it's like
this is just the [ __ ] way that I live
my life why you got to come in and get
take the [ __ ] good piece of chicken I
mean this is my house that's my chair I
want to watch my game when I want to
watch it next to my watch Silence of the
Lambs or when I watch daredevil Scott
Glenn comes up I'm gonna be like you
know this problem is he wants the good
piece of chicken so ya don't see Geo
storm also probably not a problem since
you've all not seen it do well this
weekend know it got killed this weekend
thirteen point three million dollars
they spent a hundred and forty million
on it
yeah so Wow no Jo storm - electric
Boogaloo what else came out this weekend
Madea boo Halloween cross-dressing
whatever the [ __ ] that is boo - boo -
another Madea ho another Boogaloo yeah
that was number one that was number one
20-something million dollars I give it
up her to Tyler Perry man he carries his
audience and they go with them wherever
on any journey literally any journey he
wants to take his audience will go on
he's now at this point he's like I mean
boo was based on a joke in a Chris Rock
movie remember he made the joke in top 5
about like Tyler Perry's doing Madhu boo
Ahmadiyya Halloween it was a throwaway
joke in that movie and then Tyler Perry
was like no that's not funny I am going
to do that and he did it and now he's
done a second one like anybody that ever
bags on him I'm like [ __ ] you he built
an empire like and it's no [ __ ] joke
he owns half of Atlanta yeah like he the
story of I don't what's the show he's
got Royal Pains or something but that
was the Royal Pains a show it was but
that was about doctors in the Hamptons
does that hammer know did he do
something called the pains or Royals
[ __ ] I don't know he had a TV show where
he why not a black person man I don't
know about Tyler Perry [ __ ]
he went made a hundred episodes in
advance like he made all the episodes
and then sold it to the network rather
than like the network finances of peace
but peace like that's just genius man
this is I mean again he's not he's not
making him for me but he's making him
for somebody because they're all going
he is so powerful he worked his way into
a Star Trek movie I know what a good
reason that he wanted to be in a Star
Trek I remember that he was in Jade no
yeah JJ's mm-hmm head of Starfleet
Academy because sure all right so wait
that came out this weekend and then what
else there's another big movie that
didn't quite go anywhere
snowman those billboards looked
fantastic to me but then again they look
like the Zack and Miri billboards so and
we all know what happened there
so I was looking forward to watching
that movie I like him I like I thought
the trailer looked [ __ ] badass with
like a dead person's head on a [ __ ]
snowman's body but then every piece of
literature I saw come out of the movie
not reviews people on Twitter just going
like there's it's a half a movie at best
or they thought it's worse than geo
storm really yeah and that's bad you'd
so because I'm a [ __ ] remember that
[ __ ] that I might check it on its life
is scary enough I need to go into a dark
place and be extra scared excellent
[ __ ] point I woke up this morning and
read a news story about like how that
the North Korean Defense Minister was
just like it's coming and I was like
[ __ ] man I just woke up apparently we're
getting into a war in any day now man
well also we now have bombers on 24-hour
alert so hey red and those around a lot
of people out of retirement old pilots
and stuff where I'm like you think
that's a good idea to bring old people
out of retirement for this thing just
one last ride I guess all right but
let's [ __ ] bury our head in good news
all right we got a let's see two more
things okay did you ever read the lone
wolf and cub comic books yes of course
did you like the lone wolf I've read
them I didn't understand them but I read
them it's very smart it is it's way too
smart for me there are 9,000 some odd
pages of that comic book tracking a an
executioner in feudal Japan who was
wanted by his ex Lord and revenge and
he's got a baby because it's got to
protect the baby Justin Lin is now
signed on to direct the movie version of
that at Paramount oh that's awesome
yeah except that story has been stolen
again and again and again and again
Terminator 2 is basically lone wolf and
cub to some degree for sure yeah for
sure
I mean I I love that book to death
I'm glad they spilled because I'm
sitting there going I am gonna eat them
but now that they're on the bar no I
mean yeah
don't point that out I was looking at
that gun there are nine in the cup that
didn't touch the bar you gotta want it
Jeff
yeah that's true I think that should be
a TV show not a movie that's just me I
feel like if you it is one of the great
serial stories of our time let's be
let's take it one step further the
discussion shouldn't everything be a TV
show at this point not a movie sad to
say like isn't that where everybody
wants to consume their media I mean yes
and no like they were there's still
something wonderful about like the to
our perfect experience in a movie
theater you know like as much as I would
be down for a Star Wars TV show and
there are some that I hear are very good
it's a movie thing for me okay I just I
want it that big I want it on this you
think it's because that's how it began
with you what if your kid coming-of-age
right now you give a [ __ ] of Star Wars
as a movie experience I think if
somebody was like hey man it's nine
parts on Netflix would you be just as
happy if I was a kid absolutely like
kids are screen agnostic they don't give
a [ __ ] where something is true it's
gonna be on a screen at some point
that's this big in my pocket fine and
they also don't know where anything
emanates from like I remember talking to
my kid about some show and I'm like the
Goldbergs and I was like it's on ABC and
she's like what's that and I was like
ABC the network and she's like huh
because everything she watches from and
ABC is usually on Hulu or Netflix yeah
an Eric and broadcast company one day
it's just gonna be like Network promised
one day it's one gigantic Omnicorp all
right what else well okay so hot topic
oh I like hot topic he's selling Justice
League gear and a Kevin Smith Funko pop
what exclusive at Stan Lee's comic-con
Stan Lee's Los Angeles comic-con come up
this weekend yeah you going I am I think
I'm doing a thing with Ralph Garman in
honor of Adam West at the con this year
and I'm doing a signing of my Funko pop
very cool yes I will be there Friday I
think signing copies of my comic book
genius at the Top Cow booth tell them
about your book
it is the the second mini series of an
ongoing Lodi down called genius this was
James cartel from Top Cow / image hmm
lots of blood lots of guts lots of
female empowerment and and all kinds of
punching and [ __ ] so look at you right
in comic books I thing that I've been
doing and I can't really talk about what
book it is okay I will say that for the
last four years I've been working on a
graphic novel biography of the most
famous athlete of the 20th century you
can put that together in your heads I
will neither confirm nor deny whatever
anybody shouts out from the clearly it's
Wayne Gretzky but I've been I turned in
the final draft of this 300 page graphic
novel how long ever working on it for
years four years four years Wow [ __ ]
four years of your life yeah it's crazy
man I think if I was involved in a
project and went longer than two years
I'd be like not worth it
good for you man way to stick in there
and finish yeah do a lot of research a
ton of research she talked to people um
no because it turns out that he is also
the most documented person maybe on the
planet but yes I've been doing revisions
on this thing this week and it's the
first time I've ever had to do revisions
on anything this long and it's awesome
and frightening and amazing but comic
books
yeah and that's the other end of the
spectrum much shorter now yeah look at
you master word word Smith making your
money off words using your mouth to make
money
I am your nor list I'm an oralist oral
tradition alright what else that's about
it man
there's a new mutants trailer which I
suppose we could talk about let's talk
about that which does not look like a
superhero movie at all what a great
approach how fantastic they're having
fun
over there Fox it seems like you know
everyone of course marvels define this
game at this point with the comic book
movie but Fox constantly reminding your
like hey man we were doing x-men when
nobody gave a [ __ ] and now we've been
doing it for so long we're just gonna
try different variations Deadpool was a
complete variation on the theme and
something brand-new
Logan was a complete variation of the
theme something completely new and now
it looks like New Mutants is the same
thing like when I heard they're making a
new mutants movie I'm like alright I
know what its gonna look like
then I start watching that trailer I'm
like this is the [ __ ] new mutants I'm
so in it's a horror cell looks like they
made a horror movie yet which is really
[ __ ] smart because you know directed
it the guy that made a Fault in Our
Stars Josh boom yeah he was on a podcast
one sweet [ __ ] guy but that movie
like The Fault in Our Stars looks like
the opposite of this new mutants thing
or the best version of The Fault in Our
Stars that we've ever saw where they got
all fucked-up powers and started killing
people yeah I mean it's super smart
because it's it's the best way horror is
the best way to sell a movie that does
not require stars hmm it just works
because we're in it for the genre and if
you're gonna decide to make an x-men
movie that does not have Hugh Jackman in
it and does not have like baby versions
of here as you've seen it forever right
[ __ ] sell it as horror like it goes
down so easy and the people who love
excellent movies will show up anyway
that's how you get people who don't know
it's smart what was the other trailer
they dropped as well Flash Jedi trailer
did we talk about that we talked about
that then there was another trailer this
week [ __ ] the Black Panther trailer what
you thinking to do Black Panther trailer
I'm not talking about this yet I talked
about it yeah you know I feel like I'm
gonna have to take February off I feel
as they come out mid-february think it
was 16th something like that yeah but
you need the month to just like build up
to it and then just to come down off of
it I saw Marshall today because I wanted
to pretend that it was the story of two
challahs college years like he learns to
do law before going back to what kinda
how was Marshall yeah that's alright
it's a it's no black path it's not badly
it's like it's like law and order Plus
black people which I mean it's totally
conventionally you've seen a thousand
times but Oh
awesome hey you get to do it off and
it's Chadwick Boseman Chadwick close who
else is about sterling K Brown from this
is us oh it was great and Kate Hudson
who who still looks good
what sorry Blanchett is it not Kate
Hudson who is it it's Kate Hudson I said
cute nuts and I say Kate Hudson
she thought you said Kate bat [ __ ] I
mean Kate match it yeah I what do you
think why Panther drew looked fantastic
and also now they're really selling well
Conda like even wear dental what kind of
vibe ah the chant and stuff like that
but just the nation like you know in
comics that's always been one of the
appeals of the character is there's this
secret nation that is so technologically
advanced there beyond the rest of the
world and I've just been for the last
three four days re watching the Marvel
Catalog getting ready for Thor so just
to watch them connect the dots and in
Civil War they really kind of laid the
track for Wakanda and the nation of
Wakanda and stuff I own of course
introduced to challenge Chaka his dad
it's it's thrilling you like to watch it
from your childhood come to life bless
you and to have terms said that now will
become bless you will become commonplace
for others think about how many times in
your life you've said Wakanda and if you
said that to somebody outside a certain
[ __ ] circle of friends they would
look at you like what is that now you'll
be able to say it and even your [ __ ]
grandma will be like well Conda forever
it's gonna enter the pop culture in a
big bad way I know there was something
so and I don't I don't I can't speak for
anybody else I can only speak for me and
the people who look like me I will take
it on my shoulders but there's that
there's a level of pride to that movie
there's a level of kind of unapologetic
miss to that movie like it's not asking
for space it's demanding your attention
yeah and and I've never seen that before
for a hero like that you know for you
who looks like that and for an entire
film that feels generally from that
world from the bottom up right it's it's
always been like oh hey so he's blade
and he's cool but everybody else is not
blade that's fine hey my Whistler is
cool too right there's Catwoman let's
not talk anymore about Catwoman okay you
know but like there is there is
something there I don't know it's it's
it's hard to say it's hard to put into
words precisely what I think this movie
is going to mean to a great many people
I think what like what Ryan Coogler was
able to do with Creed it seems like he's
taken to Black Panther and say done it a
hundred times over a hundred percent
over what he did in the last one it
looks phenomenal it looks a part of its
Marvel Universe as well but it also
looks completely fresh and completely
new yeah I mean it's the thing that
Marvel can do on these sort of
peripheral movies which is use your main
line here's your main heroes and then
here's [ __ ] guardians here's Thor
Ragnarok
here's ant-man here's like I rewatched
ant-man this morning such a good flow
it's a delightful movie like it's nice
to me they just decided let's make what
do you want to do on a mega [ __ ]
romantic comedy
okay go I want to make this go right cuz
you know that man and the wasp is gonna
be like a romantic comedy can't wait for
that either the hey man did you hear
Ryan Coogler is not coming back for
create - and that it's Stallone is going
to direct it and stay thought I'm not
the most excited I've look I loved
Stallone in Creed and I was glad he got
props and stuff but the most exciting
aspect of that movie was the creative
talent behind it it was I mean it to be
fair Ryan Coogler was the first person
to write a rocky movie not Stallone ever
like Stallone has been the architect of
this franchise since the very beginning
true he directed almost all of them
himself
it's like he's bad at it it's not like
he doesn't know the characters but
there's just like why you walk away from
a winning team like that or maybe Ryan
didn't want to do it maybe that's it
maybe he's like look I'm here and I'm
gonna do another one of these and said
he wants to do something maybe I want to
do my own thing like I played in your
world I played in Marvel's world and I
want to play in my world yeah but there
was a part of me that thinks that Creed
too will be lesser for not having Ryan
Coogler involved and shin actually I'd
agree with that based on how excited I
was about the last night's eminently
watchable and rewatch I'm fine like you
want to see a dude cry just put on
Creedon yeah used to be Field of Dreams
now dream yeah that's true Michael B
Jordan did all he did carry the ball in
a big bed way he was wonderful he looks
fantastic as kill mongers well black
panther alright
we talked about we've done with the news
[ __ ] it man I know you guys are tired of
looking at to [ __ ] middle-aged men
talk about pop culture let's talk to
somebody who talks pop culture on a
regular basis she does for DC all-access
she's done it for Fandango she did it
for us
on geeking out when we were on AMC last
year and and you probably got to know
her from any number of [ __ ] things
come on up Tiffany Smith ladies job
[Applause]
am I going in the middle here yeah that
cereal is really tempting right there I
know right mostly I'm doing I don't even
care I'm doing the marshmallows I mean -
bill I'm just saying I can hold my
liquor I mean but the marshmallow is so
accessible that I was like it hadn't
even go for the wins in the cup you took
the bar it was more accessible right
there fair enough
what have you been up to um so I just we
talked about this a little bit you guys
did last week but Comic Con I was in
York Comic Con which was really crazy
and awesome and what were you doing
there tell me so we live streamed for DC
all-access like two hours every day from
the floor which was crazy and the first
time we did it but it was it was one of
those things where it's like I think you
work in this industry and I grew up
reading comic books and then you do
something like this and one of the days
I was there it was the 25th anniversary
of Batman the Animated Series so Bruce
Timm was there and then I got to talk to
Frank Miller and I got to talk with
Geoff Johns and Jim Lee all in one day
and at the end of the day I was like man
I'm tired and I thought about who I got
to talk to and I was like this is my
life like it's craziness the stuff that
you get to do professionals yeah yeah
how long you been doing it when did you
start so I study see all access I
started like probably I think it was
like three or four years ago Jeni you
guys watch the show DCL access yeah yeah
I literally thought for a second I was
like no one's gonna say anything well
they're probably like oh we watched the
episodes that Kevin was on it's free on
the internet
how can you not watch it is on DC's
YouTube channel so I started that about
three or four years ago and have been
doing it ever since and then got to
start doing more stuff with CW and
Warner Brothers and that was how we
actually got connected because we did a
little you did a livestream for Batman
for Man of Steel yeah
and then I got to interview for that and
then did stuff with CW and I remember
you interviewing me for with Fandango
someplace - yes we did Sundance I think
a couple times so it was I think so cuz
I remember walking out and going like
[ __ ] man she's like way knowledgeable
and [ __ ]
you're like for a person that has to
talk to other people and then for a
person who talks to other people and
your your dream content provider because
you always have stuff to talk about your
way on top of like what's happening and
you're always talking about [ __ ] that's
kind of like right up my alley
DC specific and whatnot wait but go back
when did you start and how did you get
to DC all-access so I started hosting my
first job that I got hosting mainstream
was for g4s attack of the show yeah so I
I lived in New York City and was like if
I want to do this hosting thing I gotta
move to LA and I always compare it to
like in Indiana Jones you know when he
walks over the invisible bridge and he's
like oh god am I gonna go that was me
moving to LA I was like I have no job I
don't know what's gonna happen I had met
with people when I came out to LA but
they were like we can't offer you
anything till you're here so I moved to
LA and I'm like within two weeks of
being out here I was getting to do stuff
on attack of the show which was awesome
and for anybody who works acts hosts in
this industry it's like there's a secret
world of geeks in LA as soon as you're
in the door opens and you walk in and
you're like oh there's Seth Green there
is Nathan Fillion there's Kevin Smith
but you just kind of it's like never
been in a room with those guys I've
never been invited I just spoiled it I
know I hide that invite it's one at a
time and like once you leave they let
another one in exactly exactly you have
to battle to stay in the room apparently
I'm a lover not a fighter I can't battle
so yeah so you move that kind of that's
kind of how the whole career began at g4
and then g4 ended which was a sad day
but then that kind of led me to hosting
for Marvel so I hosted their live
streams when they first started out
which was probably one of the most
memorable I've had a lot along the way
but I remember getting to host the live
stream for the Avengers premiere and
they came up to me they're like so
you're just gonna be like the
commentator talked about everything
going on in the carpet and then they
can't watch me then they're like Kevin
doesn't want to announce everybody Kevin
Feige they want you to go onstage and
announce the whole cast and I just
remember being like oh my god I am going
to pee my pants cuz I was wearing a
dress
I got up there and I was just like I'm
literally announcing characters that I
grew up reading it was mind-blowing and
then now being at a place where working
with DC I'm like I might get to do it
again with the Justice League which is
crazy so that one would that be well
would be for the premiere but I don't
know yet there's no details yet but I'm
just kind of getting to that place where
it's like I got to do Wonder Woman I'm
like
have you gotten to see just so yeah I
have not and I was actually sitting over
there looks like I'm actually kind of
glad I haven't seen it yet because I
feel like it'd be really hard for me not
to say anything but I haven't seen it
yet no hopefully soon
so you know you might know somebody that
might know about it hey hey not just him
what'd you bring us tonight man so just
talking about kind of listening to what
you guys were saying up here I was kind
of the big news for me that I heard was
Stephen tonight was talking about who
did daredevil season 2 yeah yeah and
Spartacus but I guess in an interview he
was talking about the fact that
obviously we're getting Kong Godzilla
crossover and then they were Kong and
Godzilla in 2020 that they have a date
for that one I'm pretty sure is out in
2020 but then they were talking about
also now there's a chance there's no
Easter eggs that are for sure but then
also mixing kaiju in so it would be like
a three character crossover three film
crossover so what would the kaiju be
just from what for just that Yeager's
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it would be just
a whole multiverse thing again so just
kind of think about that like how do you
guys feel about having that many
different genres characters within one
because I feel like everyone wants to
mash everything together I mean I guess
it makes sense if you're gonna bring
kaiju into the world of Godzilla King
Kong and gods historically Godzilla has
fought what could be considered cod you
monsters right just to some degree it
that doesn't feel like an unnatural fit
it's not like do we need them all in one
movie
we need the Eggers yeah like that's what
I thought like what when you were
talking about cod you I was like oh my
god are they gonna cross Pacific Rim
over with those movies but yes that too
that was we're singing the Easter eggs I
mean I I'm all for it man like anything
that makes me go oh that's different
like even Godzilla King Kong doesn't
feel that different to me because I had
that as a child so it'll be a much
better-looking version of it but if
you're like hey we're gonna throw in
[ __ ] kaiju oh my god well now I got
some skin in the game more so than I did
in just the version of Kong and Godzilla
you yeah it's funny somebody asked me on
Twitter the other day like if I could if
I could start any universe what would it
be
yeah and my answer was just make me a
good movie you know like do not have
your eye on the universe before you give
me a decent movie to build the universe
on like don't dark universe it don't be
like oh no you there's gonna be nine of
these movies and here's our cast and
we're gonna [ __ ] roll when you don't
make one good movie yeah and if you've
got a great story to tell about Yeager's
fighting Godzilla fighting Kong all for
the fate of humanity even great but if
it's hey we have the rights to all this
we'd be two knuckleheads if we didn't
put it in a movie that feels like the
wrong reason to make that movie let me
ask you a question both of you does it
neat does that movie [ __ ] the kaiju
version just cods godzilla calm does it
need a human story at all now I'm not
saying will it have one yes but does it
even need one like honestly wouldn't you
[ __ ] pay 10 bucks to just watch like
90 minutes of Godzilla and Kong beating
the [ __ ] out of each other and never
once cutting to the ground to be like do
it calm like or whatever a [ __ ] human
story is down below like nobody gives a
[ __ ] but you know it's gonna be like
5-10 minutes of them slugging it out I
say just do it just do the fight version
[ __ ] make it 1 hour long I'll still pay
10 bucks as long as there's no [ __ ]
human story on the ground I will say
this I saw on a plane I saw a shin
Godzilla for the first time have you
seen this which one shin Godzilla it's
it's the latest out of
Japan from Toho from I think Toho's
involved in it somehow it is it's a
Godzilla movie but it is also this
incredibly trenchant look at Japanese
bureaucracy and how the the the [ __ ]
red tape keeps people from doing what
they know needs to be done so there's a
very real human story in this movie so
Godzilla being [ __ ] awesome and she
lays dreams I was back in this [ __ ]
weird ballsack version of them and then
he grows up into the giant flaming
version and it's amazing but it's also
this really smart satire and its really
smart social commentary if you do that
right mm-hmm
if there's a world in which you can
figure out the human story that makes
sense and just isn't [ __ ] people
saying what should we do
I think Godzilla should win I think it
should be Mothra Mothra's here and then
you see little like nine inch girls
shouting from our throat because they
broke out of their box where they just
call from our thoughts huh I'm down for
the good version of that all right but
if you give me the shitty version I
don't want I'm with you I'm just like
clash Royale I mean I feel like you see
those fights online like there's people
creating those awesome battles on
YouTube right now so it's like if you're
gonna do a blockbuster big-budget movie
then have a good writer involved in it
to you know not saying that there aren't
youtubers that are great writers as well
but it's like you're gonna have all that
budget behind it I would hope that we
could get both we can get think about
Godzilla remember Bryan Cranston was and
gods yes and I'm still upset that they
made that movie look like he was gonna
be in it for more than two minutes and
at the end of the day though it's like
you know that that was not the most
interesting aspect of Godzilla the most
interesting aspect of Godzilla should
always be Godzilla and that movie it was
like you saw him just as doors were
closing as suggested and stuff if you're
gonna spend the money just [ __ ] like
give it to a bunch of dudes and women
behind computers who are gonna make two
[ __ ] things that don't exist fight
each other and [ __ ] the story on the
ground man unless unless you can do what
you're talking about like then it could
be smart it's a hard [ __ ] nut to
crack
you know but I remember taking my son is
I mean was 10 - no see Gareth Edwards
Godzilla and he said you know dad for a
movie called Godzilla
there should be more Godzilla in it
kids out of the mouths of babes not
salty they're [ __ ] truth Falls that's
absolutely right so like yeah
just don't [ __ ] skip me on the
Godzilla but I have hate to be this guy
but I made a movie called clerks you
know what we have in it lots of clerks
[Laughter]
was [ __ ] clerk like you know they
talk about Star Wars but it was while
they were clerk in and [ __ ] it's not too
much to say like if you're movies called
Godzilla should be 80% Godzilla yeah I
mean I think it's funny like I remember
seeing the original Godzilla and and I
never realized why I loved it as much as
a kid as much as why why do you think
you loved it as a kid because it's never
guns in asphalt
yeah those movies are about a kid who
breaks [ __ ] in the house and didn't mean
to it's like I knocked over a lamp [ __ ]
I'm sorry dad like you did it I didn't
mean to I'm just learning how his body
works right
that's what Godzilla is I didn't mean to
destroy Tokyo you guys made me mom and
dad an atomic bomb it's not my fault you
know and I think that that you sort of
need the human story to frame that story
of Godzilla needs to be the sympathetic
hero and if it's just two things
punching each other which I'm down for I
think you just need to be able to frame
it in such a way that i emotionally
respond to it as well i think that
immediately it made me think of Edward
Scissorhands because I think it's that
same kind of vibe that happens in that
movie where it's like you put this
character who's not supposed to be in
this setup environment in it and they're
trying to fit in and they just can't and
just keep miss stepping and there is
that emotional tug there is that feeling
where it's like talk about a movie that
make like Edward Scissorhands makes me
cry and I'm not embarrassed to admit it
it totally does but it's exactly because
of that reason because there is that
emotional story and I remember seeing
Godzilla and I was like like and I'm not
saying that the actors in it are bad
actors but there wasn't a good story for
them to tell him you didn't feel
anything from them so that's why I think
in that when I was like I wanted more
Godzilla because the story was not
pulling at me I got to fill my time with
something either
we're responding to it emotionally or
smash bam sparticles and that's why we
have transformers I think here I'm stuck
on you being the only person who [ __ ]
drew a comparison between Godzilla and
Edward Scissorhands man I don't know how
I made it but you'll ant you stuck the
landing it was actually pretty good I
feel like it was I'd never really
thought about it in that way until you
were describing Godzilla that way and I
was like yeah that's that's how I feel
about Edward Scissorhands um I think we
might have talked about this little last
week but we got into it on Hollywood
babble-on this week and I just want to
throw it out there Universal cuz we
talked about the dark the dark universes
yeah supposed to be universals run at
their Universal classic monsters and
stuff now whenever Universal does their
monsters they put like Frankenstein
Dracula Wolf Man mommy Creature from the
Black Lagoon and often times they
include the Hunchback of Notre Dame
now to me isn't he a [ __ ] victim like
they always like look at this monster
and he's like it wasn't my [ __ ] fault
like they persecuted me just because the
dude looks a little [ __ ] weird they
throw him in the monster category man I
think it's tragic and I think he should
be saved or I think he's the [ __ ] big
boss he's running the monsters he's in
charge he's in charge like he's the
[ __ ] but my top and from the
bottom his entire life yeah you
[ __ ] I'm coming for you I got
monsters [ __ ] what you got I don't
think you saw that movie or read that
book what I want to happen though like
in my dream version
I loved the Hunchback much better than
the one that I saw I got a hunch [ __ ]
it's going down The Hunchback - you guys
let's find out is the part of the show
where we go Q&A style and stuff so BAM I
see a hand right there let's start with
you thanks for being here you guys sold
us out again what keeps coming back as
long as you sell us out so thank you
very much
I
trailers let me see like my favorite
trailers of all time was so
stripped-down you could never [ __ ]
sell a movie like this today but was the
first teaser trailer for Tim Burton's
1989 Batman
it was literally just a series of dry
Clips no [ __ ] score or anything like
that just an assembly really like of a
few scenes and maybe it played an hour
or like a minute and twenty seconds or
something like that but I still remember
it to this day they're very stark
approach they didn't oversell it
they literally let the visuals do the
job and they kind of did a very cut-up
there's story there was no narrator
going like he is a bad of the night like
it's just literally dialogue from the
movie like him going hi Bruce Wayne she
goes Vicki Vale and what do you do for a
living and then I cut to him dressed
like Batman and [ __ ] yank and the
dude off the the ACE chemicals like
runway whatever the [ __ ] are that that
trailer still incredibly effective I
don't understand why they don't do that
more now you think of a wonderful
trailer like the trailer the second one
they did for the Punisher where they
used Metallica and cut the [ __ ] guns
to the drumbeats and stuff and you sit
there going well that's why why would
you ever just put up an assembly of
scenes when you can artfully craft
something that puts somebody in a mood
or grabs them viscerally on that level
but that dry trailer with no score just
a series of scenes kind of cut cobbled
together you could tell they'd only been
shooting for a few weeks or a few months
or something like that and then there
was a card at the end that just had the
bat logo on it I thought it was insanely
effective and I still think about it all
the time to this day I'm periodically in
the morning when I'm awakened and bacon
I'll just watch that trailer on YouTube
remember that feeling of like oh my god
man they're coming it's coming and [ __ ]
and as before we knew what the score is
probably because they hadn't even
recorded any score with Danny Elfman yet
so there's nothing to use then it's not
like they were gonna run you know
[ __ ] 66 batman-themed under it so
they just went dry and I thought it was
really effective I'll beg you guys I
mean I think the
the interesting thing is you who said it
was like a teaser trailer it wasn't even
the full trailer which is one of the
weird things right now where it's like
you get a teaser trailer and then you
get another teaser trailer and then you
get trailer one and then you get trailer
two and that's where I think it gets
really hard because at that point you're
like have I seen too much a lot of times
you have or you've seen all of the epic
moments cuz I this is a more recent one
but I remember seeing the trailer for
Man of Steel and just that trailer I
literally I almost like wept like I just
had so much emotions and I was like this
is this this is the Clark Kent I want to
see this is the world that I want to see
and I think that it's it's something to
be said for people who cut trailers
really well that do that job but then
it's really hard because you see a
trailer like that and then those moments
there aren't quite as many of those
moments in the film as you expected
because of the trailer or you go to
Godzilla and you're like well we didn't
get Bryan grants and I don't know he was
in the whole trailer so or in the case
of mother like that Darrin I don't know
they don't explain the movie even that
trailer did that movie an incredible
disservice because it sold you a movie
that just didn't exist the trailer was
for like a Rosemary's Baby type movie
like [ __ ] horror thriller so a bunch
of people showed up looking for that and
it was it was something completely
different and what it was wasn't bad at
all but it just wasn't what people were
promised so I think a lot of people
reacted on that level but ya don't
bait-and-switch me I'm the guy though
that's like you can't show me too much I
don't give a [ __ ] if they total up 45
minutes of real movie in the trailers
like I'm I'm buying I'm in anyway so it
just makes me more excited and stuff
like that like I love people on YouTube
that gather all the trailer footage and
put it together in the like 20 minutes
of the movie and you're like oh my god
I'm gonna get baked and watch the [ __ ]
out of this what about you mark I think
one of the best modern trailers I've
seen even the modern campaigns have seen
it for baby driver I think that all of
those trailers were phenomenal because
they're not there's the movies theme and
story wise to begin with but they're
selling you on the feeling of being in
that movie they're selling you on
speed and adrenaline and propulsion and
rhythm and all of that cut together
really smartly sells that movie in a big
bad way one of my favorite trailers ever
is for this movie I want to say it's 98
I'm not sure the date could be off
little children did you guys ever see
the oh [ __ ] I love that movie love that
Kate Winslet Patrick Wilson in there as
you know she's a girl Haley is a
released pedophile sex offender and
Patrick Wilson is just like the hunky
new guy who moves into town the trailer
is just a kind of collection of shots
are the two of them like longing glances
whatever the soundtrack underneath it is
of a train approaching an intersection
so you get this building sense of
suspense just that the loud the the
wheels of the track bending
ding-ding-ding and it's all about a
collision of these people together and
once they collide their lives will never
be the same and it's telling you so
little about the movie itself except
they're selling everything about the
movie and it's this perfect little
two-minute short film that that's sound
and vision and suspense and romance and
lust and want and all those things it's
totally worth digging up because it's
amazing I love that flick what about you
favorite trailer recently or old trailer
impact I mean I definitely still say Man
of Steel but the other thing that just
came up for me this week was the Thor
Ragnarok trailer came out which I not
didn't come out but the interesting
thing was people are like cutting it
apart now because there's stuff where
Odin shows up with one background in a
teaser and now the background is
different in the trailer and Tycho
what's he had to come out and actually
he talked about it because he was like
it's nothing it's not a big deal I just
felt like the scene felt better this way
then this way but it's like we get so
many trailers like that now where it's
like everybody's analyzing every little
moment of every little trailer so
there's so much more thought that has to
go behind it where it's even talking
about the last Jedi where you know he's
like don't watch any more trailers the
director comes out didn't don't watch
anymore just go see the movie and
experience it yeah I mean there's shots
on the force awakens trailer that never
made it to the moon it's like oh we
thought this was an awesome shot so put
it in and there's bound to be shots from
all those Justice League trailers that
aren't going to make the movie in a
world where Joss Whedon is shot a bunch
of new material
that means old material is probably
gonna go particularly with a lean
running town of two hours so I guarantee
you there's footage that we've seen that
we'll never [ __ ] see in the finished
film feels like it all right where we
gonna go next bang right there many
years I did a miniseries too many series
of DC comics years ago one was called
Batman cacophony the moments called
Batman the widening gyre did them both
with Walt Flanagan the guy from comic
book men and then we there was a third
series to go Batman bellicosity and we
have three issues fully drawn four
issues written and then we started comic
book men and that was seven seasons ago
so comic book men got in the way of us
finishing that but it was also not one
of those things where the whole world
was banging down our door going we got
to know the ending but there are enough
people out there where like for the last
two years being well have been talking
about doing it at DC last year I was
there for something else I'm related and
Jim Lee and Dan to do were both like
it's time to finish that that Batman
book with Walter you know so you know I
just told Walt that too like Jim Lee was
on comm pokeman for one episode and he
turned to Walter like out of nowhere and
he was like you ever gonna finish that
Batman book and Walter was like you
heard about that you know so yes we will
definitely be getting back to it
hopefully this is the year for sure okay
hasn't been done yet I'm still looking
for a film noir of the question I think
that'd be really really cool something
like blood simple but with Vic sage or
Renee Montoya as the question I think
that character is visually interesting
as [ __ ] horrifying on some level because
there's a it's a featureless face and
you know you're basic
doing murder mysteries and stuff so I
would that's the one I'd lean toward you
I always go to Zoot ona I want to see
more I want to see more magic from the
world of DC I feel like we've gotten to
see a lot of the superheroes the supers
and I'm ready for more of the magical
side of things I think we got a little
bit with Constantine and we could have
delved even deeper into that so and I
think it would definitely have to be a
little bit darker a little bit more
adult feeling I don't know that it can
be like the bright happy world but I
feel like there's that circusy feeling
that you could get where there's a
creepiness to it but it's still colorful
that would be really cool within that
space that's what I would want to see I
think I want to see a Batman movie
that's actually a detective story
because I feel like most of the Batman
movies do not involve the world's
greatest detective actually detecting
much of anything
no just the world's richest man with a
lot of toys yeah you know and punching
his way into and out of stuff like I I
want I want the Sherlock Holmes of it I
want I want that I want the Sherlock
Holmes meet Zorro that bad Batman was
always supposed to be we get a lot of
the Zorro we get a lot of the rich guy
playing the flop who's got all the toys
that a man can one we do not get a lot
of the dude who is smarter than
everybody else on the stage that's kind
of what I miss hey before we go
someplace else real quick you watching
The CW shows oh yes I'm pretty current I
think I might be one episode - have you
noticed this season that Supergirl last
year flash went dark and Supergirl was
very comic book II with aliens fighting
in broad daylight and stuff this season
they seem to have switched tones flash
has become very comic book and comical
as well they've started leaning in
toward the comedy in a big bad way and
Supergirl has gone pretty starkly
serious yeah I did notice that but I
feel like it's wouldn't when the flash
first came out that was what they leaned
on so much was the comedy of it the
lightheartedness and I remember when
that one came out I used to watch
Smallville and like TGIF with my family
and there wasn't something that you
could watch
as a family and get that feeling from it
and that it wasn't you know too sexual
or too whatever and that was what the
flash was the first season and then I
think that in a good way they took those
characters to a different place and
played with some different stuff and
then now we're getting to lighten it up
a little bit more and that for sure is
coming across and I think with Supergirl
it's like you've got so many actors on
that show where just the moments between
the sisters on that show Mazin are so
good but I want more of that on the
flash I love the fact that Grant is so
funny and Carlos and you know those all
those actors I think they play comedy so
well not saying that they don't on
Supergirl but I feel like they're kind
of leaning into what each set of actors
does best so I'm excited that it's going
that direction and that there is more
emotion because this season the stuff
that even just Melissa we're you know
she's having to play a lot more of the
emotional side of things and the hard
things that Supergirl has to deal with
that you don't necessarily think you're
gonna get with Supergirl but you're
getting them and it's so good eloquent
all right where are we going next sure
you don't have to stand but that's
adorable but go ahead moved here from
Delaware right on man thank you a
blueprint you know honestly just trust
in yourself and trust in your friends
like there's a reason you came out here
you know and it's not just because you
like this is where they make entertain
ixnay I can make entertainment anywhere
and stuff there's a calling you you're
hearing it like in that that [ __ ]
dopey Kermit song Rainbow Connection
there's the line where they say you know
have you been - sleep and have you heard
voices I've heard them calling my name
something's calling you that says like
you want to be a part of something that
you've watched and and for many people
it's okay to just spectate it's okay to
watch but then there's a certain
percentage where you can watch only to a
certain point before you're like well I
want to play - that looks fun like and
and the longer you watch and the longer
time goes on you start to realize
there's really nothing holding you back
from at least trying or heading toward
it if that's the thing you're kind of
interested in how old are you you just
turned 30
so I'm 47 so you're 1 like generation
below me let's say right now your
generation like my generation was raised
to be like you got to go to college and
that's the road to success you know
otherwise you're just gonna join
somebody else's job you know work for
somebody else the only way to prosperity
was you know [ __ ] through higher
academia and stuff but now like your
generation and the generation under you
and stuff like that they're told
differently they're just like hey man
figure out what you love to do then
figure out how to get paid to do it and
that's the [ __ ] secret to life so
you're halfway there you've now figured
out what you love to do and now you just
gotta figure out how to get paid to do
it in my case it was a weird you know I
was never in it for the money so the
money was way
down the road I just wanted to make a
movie that's once see clerks so once
that happened it kind of opened the
doors to everything else and I could
have just stayed as a filmmaker and
stuff and practiced and gotten better at
that you know if you've seen tusk you
know that's not the case but for me it
was more interesting to try a bunch of
different things
movies opened up the door to like oh I
can write comic books and in 1990 what
was a seven 97-98 like wanting to write
a comic book and working in this
business they were antithetical like my
agent was like why would you do that
they only pay it like a hundred dollars
a page what a waste of time I'm like
because I grew up reading this [ __ ] and
the chance for me to like now because of
this stupid movie I made I might be able
to write [ __ ] Green Arrow oh my god
I'm gonna [ __ ] try I'm gonna go and
talk to them and hopefully it'll pan out
and it did so I just lean toward things
that I liked like that's what got me
there in the first place I just wanted
to see that movie clerks I'd seen
Richard Linklater made slacker I was
like [ __ ] I want to see if I can make a
movie and I did and it opened up the
door but rather than like be the guy who
like Robert Rodriguez you know he made
his first film and then he concentrated
on his craft he's brilliant filmmaker
most of my peers are brilliant
filmmakers you know people who practice
their craft and [ __ ] and do it over and
over again speak the language of cinema
as much as like I love movies and that's
what got me in there are too many other
interesting things like I'd rather
[ __ ] podcast than practice my visual
arts I'd rather obviously we're doing
one right now you know we're in the
midst of it I'd rather like you know
write a comic book I'd rather [ __ ]
interview somebody or go stand on a
stage and talk like there were other
ways to story tell in the beginning and
there's just that one way like oh [ __ ]
Richard Linklater made a movie I'll make
a movie and I could be a storyteller but
that opened up a lot of opportunities to
tell stories other places and as long as
you don't give a [ __ ] about the money
you'll go interesting [ __ ] places and
I know it's tough not to give a [ __ ]
about the money we all got to get paid
we all got a pair of pills but as long
as you can pay your bills and stuff and
leave yourself enough freedom to let go
like I don't try this now I'm gonna try
this now
look it helped in my case that something
established me and then I could go off
and try other things but that
establishment I know a lot of
people think like I'm probably [ __ ]
make more money than I do but I never
made a bunch of money making those
movies and [ __ ] like that and I still to
this day haven't made a bunch of money
this is not me crying poor by any
stretch of the imagination people pay me
ridiculous money to stand around and
talk about Batman so I'm very [ __ ]
lucky but that being said it's like I
live hand-to-mouth
I have no massive savings like basically
money comes in we pay our bills and then
all the money's gone and then I go back
to work and then there's more money and
stuff so it's a pretty much like
everybody else it's just you know well
the money's different because it's an
entertainment and [ __ ] but the money's
never been the draw
I've always sacrificed making more money
to do something that I thought was
interesting maybe it's not gonna pan out
maybe it's not gonna pay as much as this
and I'll never get as respected as most
of my peers who've actually gotten way
better at their job you think about it I
made clerks way before Chris Nolan made
[ __ ] following let alone memento and
I'm still talking about clerks but when
was the last time you ever heard Chris
Nolan go like oh I made a movie called
memento once you know like he talks
about Dunkirk and he talks about
whatever he's doing that's because he's
in forward motion but I'm the person
that like you know I made clerks and for
the next 20 years I was like did I tell
you I made clerks once
you know because I have this whole other
career of just talking about the things
that I've done so it's been a
distraction from getting great at the
one thing that I was known for in the
beginning but I don't care I was never
in it to win awards or become a master
craftsman I just wanted to tell a story
I just want to tell that one story and
then all of a sudden I was able to tell
other stories and rather than just focus
on like what was just doing in movies
his movies are ridiculously expensive
like it's so much easier to think about
the story I just literally told you it's
all words all time not dime so I want to
make a movie of that I'd be like oh my
god give me 20 million dollars in Ben
Affleck you know it's like it's much
easier to sit down and just talk rather
than like try to craft images
particularly because the [ __ ] I tend to
make movies about it's very small it's
for people talking to each other and
that's kind of what podcasting is anyway
so I don't know if any of that helps
whatsoever that my best piece of advice
is anything that you're interested in
lean toward it here you can't guarantee
it it won't become part of your life or
your career or you know somehow enrich
you either monetarily or or spiritually
or something but these are the two
things I say to myself after everything
I do whether I enjoy the results or I
don't enjoy the results the first thing
I always say is you wanted this like no
matter what happens I'm like you wanted
this you once thought this was so
[ __ ] important that you reshape the
entire universe and inconvenience a [ __ ]
ton of people to make yoga hosers so
youyou wanted this like enjoy it that's
one thing and then the other thing I
always tell myself is what was the
alternative like honestly what was the
alternative if I didn't try that thing I
would have sat around my whole life
going like what would it have been like
if I did it oh my god we should still do
it and it would haunt me and [ __ ] I'd
rather get it out of my system try it it
doesn't work out great whatever you know
that what that means it's practical it's
manufactured for you so let me say I
have this dream of this thing I want to
do two options either you do it or you
don't do it and then it haunts you until
the day you [ __ ] die so let's say I
choose to do it
I don't do it go on this is gonna be
bridge to success I do it go on this is
me doing that
and its best results the best reward I'm
gonna get out of this is it's gonna
exist it didn't exist and it's gonna
exist I'm not looking for the whole
world to [ __ ] love it I'm not looking
for it to make a bunch of money that
[ __ ] would be great
believe me and I wouldn't say no if that
happened but I don't aim toward that
because you can't plan for success
nobody can I don't give a [ __ ] man like
Thor is about to come out I guarantee
you everyone at Disney then Thursday
night they're gonna clench their
[ __ ] go and I hope this works even
though they know that movies probably
gonna work but there's no [ __ ]
guarantee the [ __ ] nuke could come
over from North Korea and suddenly that
ruins the box office for the weekend and
[ __ ] like that so with no guarantee of
success you have to do it for other
reasons and the reason to do it is
because you're like I need to do it I
need to do it it's very masturbatory but
you're like I have to get it out of my
system if I'm ever gonna continue on in
life so it's worth doing if it haunts
you that much those two things are
always worth remembering you wanted this
but more importantly like what was the
alternative what were you gonna do just
sit there for the rest of your life go
like I always wanted to try that but I
didn't you get one go-around as far as I
know and this is what we don't know what
happens when you [ __ ] die a lot of
people that will tell you go be with
Jesus or somebody else and [ __ ] like
that and there's a bunch of people that
tell you that you're a computer that
winds down and when you're done you're
[ __ ] done one of the scariest yet most
beautiful [ __ ] moments of death that
I've seen recently that made me
contemplate my own and reshape my world
in a way I'm like oh my god I'm gonna
die it's never where you expect it it
was in an episode of Rick and Morty in
the season finale the season finale of
Rick and Morty had one of the most
terrifying yet real moments to me that
actually put me on a thought process of
like man I got to [ __ ] live
differently it was the moment where
they're in the spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode they're in the Oval
Office
and you know the president's like arrest
this man about about Rick and so a like
a Secret Service man is approaching him
and Rick goes son you don't have to
listen to that order and I guarantee if
you touch me you're gonna die and he
goes and and
nothing happened he goes and when he
died nothing happens it just goes black
don't do it and then the kid touches him
[ __ ] drops dead and everybody in the
room goes what happened he goes he's
dead and he's going what is that he goes
it's called a deterrent they're like you
couldn't have just knocked him out and
he's like how is that a deterrent
everyone wants to be knocked out nobody
wants to be dead but that moment of him
gone like and there's no afterlife son
it's just all black like i sat there
going like my whole life I was raised
Catholic man all I was sold was an
afterlife pain in this life joy in the
[ __ ] next and stuff and the older I
get the more I realize [ __ ] I was sold
the [ __ ] fairy tale there's nobody
knows the [ __ ] truth what happens on
the other side and you know if I'm gonna
believe father Dalzell from childhood I
gotta believe Dan Harmon and Justin
roiland know just as much and I gotta
tell you their vision of what happens in
the end is far more terrifying than
anything they ever told me in church so
it just makes you go like you got one go
around you don't know you could be like
that dude and Rick and mortar you touch
brick and you [ __ ] died and that was
it and [ __ ] your whole life's over
might as well lean toward the things
that you want to try now if you you know
I want to try killing children I'm not
[ __ ] talking to you
you know but if you're like I want to
try creating [ __ ] then I'm all for that
there's two paths in this world
destruction and creation pick creation
it's way better it's way more fun just
as long as you don't expect the whole
world to agree with you at all times
sometimes they will sometimes you gonna
make [ __ ] everyone's gonna be like oh my
god you're so clever and then sometimes
you're gonna make [ __ ] and people be
like you've lost it you know but it
don't matter you're not doing it for
them you're doing it for you
good all right let's go somewhere less
heady and more pop-culture II over here
go I know my answer be like clerks three
so you go it wouldn't be a movie it
would be a TV show much your point I
want to make a secret of NIMH TV show
really yeah why you're a fan of the book
I was never at the book I was a huge fan
of the Don Bluth movie but that world is
so [ __ ] dense and thick and rich like
me an octave like me it's it's it's Game
of Thrones with mice and rats and I
think that you can absolutely get a
hundred episodes out of that that would
be fascinating and riveting and
blood-curdling and cuz [ __ ] super
intelligent rats are frightening from
every level but no that's if you could
convince MGM to give me like seventy
million dollars I would do that until I
died happy all right
no especially when he [ __ ] pulls
secret of NIMH out of his ass suddenly
every answer is gonna be pale in
comparison like I'm the one who's like
bright stuff for me and I'll say it I
think recently I was talking a lot about
just do it like obviously Star Wars I do
a podcast or a show all about Star Wars
obviously as well on Collider or Jedi
Council and I'm Smith Lord on yeah and
did I counsel are you Smith Lord Smith
Lord yet you can't take it even though
you're a Smith I would probably want to
do an underworld kind of seedy
underbelly of Star Wars and I would want
it to be on Netflix and III always go
towards the darker side of things
because I feel like in life I'm pretty
light-hearted I'm pretty happy and peppy
so when I think about what I want to
watch on TV you get the game of Thrones
I want the dirty gritty side of things I
want to see the bounty hunters I want to
see pirates I want to see scout
girls I want to see that world of Star
Wars that I feel like we're never really
gonna get on the big screen because they
can't really get into the grit as much
so that's what I would want to see for
movies
each one book of the Dark Knight Returns
instead of all this like hey man it's
three movies it's what do they call it
[ __ ] trilogy instead of all this
trilogy [ __ ] thank you I thought
that was going to be harder I can't
believe I smoked that word away is it
triptych is triptych too smart we got it
I'd go for a quartet man each one of
those books is dense enough thick enough
to provide content for its own movie and
in a world where you've now trained the
audience to expect interconnected movies
you know III think that could totally
work I mean yes you could do it on
Netflix as well but you know it's Batman
let's put them in a theater although you
know I'll be all for Batman on TV did
you as you see arrow this week
references Oliver Queen literally
reference Bruce Wayne which I think was
the first time on that show oh the other
one I want I want Jem and the Holograms
that's my always go to but not the
version that we got I remember the
triage in a trailer for the five million
dollar version of Jim I thought was
pretty effective but it wasn't it didn't
match that cartoon but not like the cart
you did anybody watch the cartoon yeah
yeah yeah I feel like it I loved it I
was like musicals positive message it's
bright and colorful I wanted a movie
version of it not like what we got I
will give you a movie though because I
feel like I cheated I would want to
readapt the running man by Richard
Bachman / Stephen King based on the
based on the original novella which is
this super harrowing tale about this
dude who super broke who basically
mortgages his life to compete in a
reality show where he's hunted across
the the country and it's this super like
it's reality TV before those reality TV
it's this really kind of deep social
satire that ends with if I remember
correctly your hero flying a plane into
the broadcast tower of the network
that's what happens at the end yeah
spoiler for a 30 year old book
but you know it's it's it's really it's
science fiction at its highest level
which is it's about social like science
fiction for as nerdy and as wonky and
technobabble as it can be science
fiction is always about us reframed in a
way that we can look at us and not
notice us you know so it's it's that
kind of thing it's looking at at income
inequality it's looking at the
prevalence of reality television it's
looking at the petite of the media that
area wants to suckle at it's looking at
it's it's way more relevant today than I
think it was when I was written they'll
never make a movie cuz you can't have
your hero end and flying a plane into a
skyscraper but it's my god you're right
yeah tough yeah tough tough meeting I
think yeah they'd have to rethink that
one I think so too
all right where we going next get two
more and get out of here yes this Gary
oh [ __ ] all right we'll go there and
then we'll go there go I'm sorry I love
the movie I thought the movie was
wonderful but what is that the TV show
who's is there anybody behind the movie
behind the TV show I think bong Joon who
is that it how you pronounce his name
the Korean filmmaker is consulting at
the very least if not an active
participant in the show Josh Friedman
who wrote War of the Worlds and
determinated the Sarah Connor Chronicles
is the showrunner on it I can't remember
who the star is but they cast somebody
big didn't they
Jennifer Connelly and the DEA is playing
who dared a new character because it was
Chris Evans wasn't right so it's it's
like it's not based off him it's new
stuff not the book not the graphic novel
I'm not sure how deep they're going on
whatever look twenty years or whatever
the name of the French book is my
pronunciation is also Ryan school sched
there is based on French comme yeah yeah
I don't I don't I don't know but I'm I'm
all for it because those people are
smart and I love the movie the movies
like this weird [ __ ] awesome
chambered where every car is a different
movie and half those cars make no sense
at all and I don't care but why is there
a sushi car why go for sushi that's why
not
I loved the movie I read the book and
loved it and what I enjoyed so much
about the film was that it felt like
playing a videogame in some ways where
it's like you kind of just go through
the next level next level next level and
then it's a totally different space and
I think that you know words Chris Evans
has talked about this where you know he
really enjoys doing the smaller kind of
indie films where he can really delve
into his acting so he'll flip-flop back
and forth between like say a huge Marvel
film and then something like that where
it's kind of in-between and so for me
when you get a movie that is so similar
to the comic in that way it makes me so
happy when it works because a lot of
times there's comics and you do it and
you're like it only works in this way if
you try and do it exactly the same we're
so similar it doesn't really work on the
screen but that one really does so I'm
curious I'm sorry what is that
today extended edition I like the
extended one I loved I feel like The
Watchmen is an amazing translation but
not a good adaptation the best is me but
they're making that again aren't they
they're doing it talking about doing on
HBO
yes unclear what that story will be
either except that it's not the book hey
man Chris Evans like I actually feel he
gets to act as a soften those Captain
America movies like I remember like I
set him once on The Tonight Show the Jay
Leno Tonight Show years back and I think
it was after they had done Captain
America the First Avenger and I think
they had started the Avengers where it
was done but it wasn't out yet so
between like commercials and [ __ ] like
that like because they sat us next to
each other which is [ __ ] embarrassing
because we look like the number ten and
and and so he so between you know
commercials I was like hey man wasn't
like housing Marvel Man Captain America
and he was just like they don't let you
act stand here you say this you got to
be there for this moment cuz it's all
about the CGI and he seemed kind of like
down like you know I don't get to act
much but meanwhile like Captain America
2 & 3 and and Avengers 2 like he acts
his ass off like he's made Captain
America a compelling character for me I
was a kid my whole life and I was always
like Captain America it's [ __ ] boring
he actually made Captain America like
likable I like his performance I think
he's a really good actor in that role
particularly I mean I was talking on
line a little bit earlier this week
about Robert Downey jr. versus Chris
Evans and I love Robert Downey jr. Tony
Stark oh so much but I feel like it's
Robert Downey jr. yes as Tony Stark
Foster yes he's showing up as our DJ
doing that things I give me money cuz
he's great yes we can have all mine
totally like but I think Chris Evans is
doing an infinitely harder thing I agree
which is making an unvarnished unyk sort
of Boy Scout yes a compelling character
and giving him shades and and depth like
that's [ __ ] hard
there's no jokes in Captain America
there's no wry ironic twinkle in his
eyes there's just I'm gonna do the right
thing because it's the right thing and
it's hard to make compelling like he's
killing it in a role that should not be
easily killed agreed I think that it
that because we've gotten more films
he's been able to do more because it's
like you the Verret the first Iron Man
movie I still think is one of the best
superhero films afroman
yeah we really set that whole template
so good and because it wasn't Robert
Downey jr. playing Tony Stark yet it was
Tony Stark I disagree I think a lot yeah
a lot of the fun of watching that movie
particularly in the end when he's
talking about like clearly I couldn't be
a superhero with this long list of
character defects people probably a lot
of people don't remember now but like
there was a whole period of our lives
where he was the guy who is like Robert
Downey jr. woke up in a stray
changers house today you know and you
were like oh man what happened to him
and that's so long gone you don't even
think about it but when that movie hit
you were like oh it's a perfect fit
like Tony Stark as a as an arrow do well
he's got kind of a similar background it
worked well I thought that that was
there from the jump and it worked so
well and like remember he was a guy they
made audition like a studio was
paramount and they were like I don't
know if we want this guy who they wanted
a younger guy so they signed him for one
movie and paid him peanuts so the next
movie they had to actually pay him full
freight and like and then his check got
bigger and bigger and what I always
loved about that is like he just got
paid more and more to be himself over
and over again like it's ingenious and
it's not saying it's not acting he's
clearly acting but he's acting like
Robert Downey jr. one half the time it's
like a lot of the acting is just this
part just like there's just a camera
right here and he's like all right I'm
gonna wear my PJs just get my face done
truly who else was on that list for Tony
Stark I don't know I'm just asking which
no no that would be good too five who
Tom Cruise was that true but that would
have been then he was older than Robert
Downey jr. at that point I thought they
wanted to go younger they were like we
want a kid miss 20s
yeah or a legit movie star I'm sure
because Paramount isn't a Tom Cruise
business that's true I remember that
John Krasinski was on the list for cap
well that would have been good I can see
that and Charlie Hunnam was on the list
for Thor okay I could see that I guess
yeah I mean yeah until you see Chris
Hemsworth yeah clearly that guy and this
whole [ __ ] family where do we go next
yes how did Kevin and Mark meet and
start podcasts where do we meet what's
your recollection my recollection is I
was working for Entertainment Weekly
and I pitched them on doing a
filmography with you when zack and miri
was coming out i think hmm and so reach
out to your PR and they said sure here's
his email and email these like hey let's
set a time I'll get in the phone we'll
talk through some [ __ ] you were like hey
can we do this over I am because I'd
much rather write and talk don't know
who that Kevin Smith was I was like sure
I don't have to transcribe anything
that's awesome and so we interviewed
talked for like two hours online and
then like every like three weeks you'd
pop up my my I am with like a dude is
this a commerce semicolon
like you're an editor you should know
these things how does this work I was
like do you put the comma inside a
quotation or outside a quotation mark
human spellcheck I was I was his copy
desk and but then it would just search
it if I was like hey man did you see
that movie did you see daredevil these
I'm in daredevil or whatever and then it
became like nerd [ __ ] and then he said
hey do you play cards and I said yeah
well but I play it's like I got a hot I
got a poker game we do in Jersey at the
store it's like I live in Jersey you
should come to the game so I came to the
game and won a lot of money the first
time yes and then realized that it was
not a good idea to win a lot of money
every other time so then lost a lot my
wife was like why do you keep on going
and drama like $400 I got a not win from
the rich guy I never won myself you know
you were good no way yeah and then I
would come out to LA for work or pre
comic-con any but like yeah I come to
the house I do this podcast with my wife
you should you should be a guest sure
man oh come on
and it was plus one with jam I came in
one morning mm-hmm and then I keep went
back to New York and then came back out
the following year is like hey there's
this this Paley event for this new
Batman animated movie we should do a
super [ __ ] commentary track for a Dark
Knight Returns I'm like yeah all right
[ __ ] it let's do that like that was fun
let's do all of the Batman movies all
right sure that's cool hey that was fun
let's do Gotham yeah all right this is
not fun let's just talk about nerve
that's true Gotham was the show that
broke her back it really was we got like
three episodes it's like dude I cannot
keep doing Gotham I understand it's
gotten way better everyone's like you
need to watch it now if they see that
every [ __ ] season it starts a guys
you got a watch Gotham look I know
sooner or later I will catch up one of
these days
basically it's Kevin saying do you mind
if we and may say yeah man that's cool
mind if we set up some cameras in here
yeah man that's cool you want it man if
we just put on YouTube sure man you want
to do some live shows [ __ ] it let's do
Comic Con all right yeah let's do a
standard thing if this [ __ ] Cantina
all right it just kind of grew
organically it really did it's it's him
saying do you mind if we do this in me
saying yeah man that sounds like fun
here's why I'll always love Marc they
did a while he was in Entertainment
Weekly at San Diego comic-con mm now you
don't want to say yes summer 2008
because zack and miri came out like two
months later he put me on a panel in
Hall H with and it was called what was
it it was the Entertainment Weekly
presents the visionary visionaries and
the visionaries in question were Judd
Apatow Zack Snyder Frank Miller and me
so clearly one of these things is not
like the other so Marc put me in really
good company and that was at a time in
my life when I desperately desperately
needed Judd Apatow to tell me yes I saw
your movies and so on that panel
we were chit-chatting somebody Judd
Apatow like said like Kevin Smith laid
the track and I gave him the biggest
[ __ ] hug I didn't prompt him I wasn't
like can you [ __ ] say it but in my
heart of hearts I was like god I hope he
says something and he did he was like
Kevin Smith laid the track and I gave
him the biggest [ __ ] hug in the world
it was nice because his movies were
blown the [ __ ] up and people were like
hey his movies in like your movies
except they make money what's the
difference
so it was really really nice but mark
putting me on that visionaries thing was
was a big deal for me I always remember
that very fun it was awesome for me
because Kevin and Judd like to talk
Zach sweetest man in the world can't
really stitch a bunch of words together
into sentences and Frank was like old
and grumpy and I read so like I'd ask
him I stole your deafness spirit what's
what's it like you know you've had some
of your groundbreaking works adapter for
the screen what's it like taking another
person's work of similar stature he's
like it's alright yeah they were very
circumspect answers especially
considering he wrote The Dark Knight
Returns which is a very wordy book so I
always imagined him with a question and
he would hold court and do like a five
minute response but he was like it's
good and that was that the words for the
comic like say so you did the same thing
with Watchmen like what what kind of you
know mental hurdles did you have to jump
over to be able to tackle such an
important piece of work and he would
just kind of perambulate around an
answer that was basically like it was
hard but it would take him two minutes
to say it was hard
alright like dude you're you're lovely
you're wonderful like but ya gotta give
me some copy dude you got it there's
people here he's gotten much better at
that like it was one of the first times
he had to do that I think you're
absolute maybe one of his first tall H
appearances but he's become quite a Hall
H master like he learned to play that
room very very well I remember when they
dropped that Batman V Superman trailer
the first time [ __ ] goddamn it
alright is that it should we wrap it
what there's one there go ahead I don't
I have no John Peters stories that I
never told back in the day you know that
I remember when that when John snaps
wonderful documentary The Death of
Superman lives what happened came out so
good it used to be on Showtime I don't
know
there anymore but if now you can find
online and buy it it's [ __ ]
phenomenal I got to see him in the
documentary and I hadn't seen him since
like 1996 John Peters and like he the
thing I loved about the doc was like for
years I've been telling John Peter
stories and people were like you just
you're kind of blowing it out of
proportion are you making a big cartoon
and [ __ ] and then he literally gives the
on-camera interview and it validates
almost everything I ever said where
you're like oh my god he is kind of that
guy like right down to the point where
he's like putting moves wrestling moves
on people he's like I've been in 500
street fights so amazing so no no I
there was no really nothing I'm trying
to think you know no he way I remember
he went to the Chasing Amy premiere I've
talked about that I don't know if it was
in the story that I told on the DVD but
I remember he went to the chasing a me
premiere we had in Santa Monica and he
was very impressed by the fact that it
was only $250,000 he was like 250,000
that's what that cost 250,000 he's like
[ __ ] will pay more than that for a new
draft of your script and I was like
thanks but ya know I think I spent I
think I shot my wad with all my Peter
stories is that good guess what this
week folks Halloween's coming up what is
today so it's a week from tomorrow if
you're hard up for a costume my whole
life I want to you know costume shops
and stuff like that as a kid I loved
Halloween I love like you know dress ups
for theatrical and [ __ ] like that
although I'm not a costume guy don't I
mean I live in a costume I cosplay
myself every day but I don't I don't
like get dressed up for Halloween [ __ ]
but I love to go Ptolemy's stores go
shopping while my kid was growing up
we'd always go to Oz and stuff they do a
whole Halloween [ __ ] set up and [ __ ]
like that
so for years I'd go there and you would
see like licensed versions of movie
characters and sometimes like unlicensed
suggested versions of characters you
know that was like oh it's not it
it's it's supposed to be Tom Cruise in
risky business but they can't call it
that so they'll be like risky adventure
outfit or something like that so I
always go to come to comic-con some
stores and I'd look to see if they ever
did you know drug dealers outside
convenience stores you know I always
wish to god they would do Jay and Silent
Bob because that would be a true mark of
like you've made it if you were store
bought costume you [ __ ] made it well
the folks at fun.com this year have
released a silent bob costume ladies
Gellin the bearded hair it comes with a
fake beard and all that but look at how
[ __ ] happy that guy is
it's so weird cuz they could have got me
to do it I would have totally I would
have totally put on this outfit and
taking the picture and been that guy but
it's I got one here it's a large so
who's let's what happened I helped you
guys get married add to Babylon you're
asking me to marry you this was the
customer give me a guys we got a
personally could let's see if we could
do it let's quiz let's do a quiz okay
who everybody's people like now there's
a competitive edge all right we need a
question oh [ __ ] let me see this was not
playing oh no I should have brought 70
of them and then we could just giving
them out okay I got a question you got
one guy yeah okay okay kind of question
it is it's a question about animation
would you get that [ __ ] microphone up
to your mouth it's a question about
how animation okay so it's an animation
animation question and so whoever yells
out the answer first wins the costume
yes
is it a multi-part answer like you have
to say a paragraph or just a title give
me the movie title Oh beautiful that's
not Batman Batman should just be the
winning answer for everything all right
here we go what in what Brad Pitt movie
does he refer to humans as noids
world I did win it [ __ ] but I already
got one of these all right so let's do
another one I was like oh my god Brad
Pitt was only in one animated movie cool
world felt like I was on a game show for
a minute all right you got another one
stacked up like planes on the runway you
you got one do you have a trivia
question Oh pick you I see let's see
well I was gonna say which superheroes
both name mother's name Martha but uh
what's this who [ __ ] marvel trivia
cards
well done JC well that's a true/false
let's not do that that's also true false
that's awesome are these for children
these are too hard
he's gonna start reading them and saying
like you know password but it's like
don't say V and third is way too
difficult when you're referencing
Franklin the child of you know sue
Richards and Reed Richards that's deep
that's deep cuts um [ __ ] man I hate when
you can't end the show because you can't
think of it I hate when you can't in the
show cuz the co-host [ __ ] it up
Susheela trying to be spontaneous name
me one of the two black people and die
hard the act of characters that's
alright
you left me hanging man congratulations
your winner well done well the oh [ __ ]
well [ __ ] man that was it ended so
awkwardly but but what a fun showed you
all have a good time this evening ladies
and gentlemen I would like to thank our
gracious hosts JC and company here at
scum and villainy Cantina right here in
Hollywood and of course
Tiffany man give it up for Tiffany
ladies gentlemen we are back here on
November 14th I'm back and do a show
here on November 14th tickets I think go
on sale tomorrow and stuff so come on
back if you're in this neck of the woods
thanks for being here tonight for fat
man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I am aqua
Norton who are you I'm the other Smith
Tiffany Smith tune in next time same fad
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you